[Music]
welcome to the QuickStart tutorial for
the bigquery web UI head over to the
navigation menu and find bigquery listed
on there Big Data bigquery provides some
public datasets that we can access for
the first part of this QuickStart
we'll use a data set of USA names
between the years 19 2013 here is a
query editor let's find out what the
most common names are in our data set on
the lower right side there's a green
check mark icon when we click it it runs
a query validator that will tell us if
our query is valid without having to run
it if our query is invalid it will tell
us the error so that we can go back and
correct it otherwise we're good to go
click run to run our query the results
will appear below we can view the query
results as a table or in JSON format we
also have the option to save the results
how about if we want to load our own
data to check this out we'll use a txt
file that contains the most common US
baby names of the Year 2014 this is what
the file looks like a comma separated
value file CSV with three columns to
load this test data into bigquery
let's create a dataset in the navigation
panel in the resources section click
your project name then over on the right
in the details panel click create data
set for data set ID let's enter baby
names for data location we'll put United
States we can leave all other fields
with their default values and click
create data set we've got a data set now
we can load the data into a new table
back over in the resources section we'll
see our baby names data set under our
project click it in the details panel
click create table let's change the sort
from empty table to upload click browse
and find the CSV file with our data in
it we also want to make sure that we
select the right file format CSV will
give our table a name names underscore
2014 and toggle edit as text to define a
schema name string gender string and
count integer click create table
now that we've loaded data into a table
we should be able to query it click
compose new query let's find out the top
5 male names in our table click run and
we'll get the results here below the
query window and voila that's a quick
start on big queries web UI
you